all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
comer today we'll be going over very
basic chess games and in the audience we
have a as you might remember Sundaram
from the big blitz match all right so I
expect a lot of great answers from you
today Sundaram okay all right sounds
great
all right so in the first game I am
playing the black pieces against my
students from a Ferguson okay so let's
see it's their sixth week of chess let's
see if they've progressed that all all
right
so f4 that's a legal move okay so I
played the move e5 and not d6 this is a
trick I don't know if anybody's seen the
trick you're hoping that they take here
okay and then you would take and then if
they play a random move like Knight to
c3 can you tell me how we have a quick
knockout here Queen h4 check their only
response is g3 our queen takes g3 well
Bishop takes c3 Pontic should we take a
free rook nothing like a free rook right
why Drake huh okay yeah
checkmate okay yeah it was a quick
knockout yeah it was so so you have to
watch out when so when it somebody plays
f4 which is called the birds opening
because it's far the birds obviously f45
d6 and then you if they take you take
with the bishop so you sacrifice a pawn
they have to either respond with the
move
g3 now or Knight f3 but when they play
Knight f3 you just attack it right if
they're dumb and they attack your bishop
you got a quick checkmate
if they do this you know then it's gonna
be it's not gonna be very fun for them
and now you can take the free rock okay
so so that's that's something I would
recommend to play and so alright so in
the game a fortunate it did not take it
they played the move a four very
scholastic like they love getting those
rooks out as fast as possible so Knight
up attacks the pawn so Brooke a three I
take discovered attack and so now
they've get the rock out to e3 so so it
is basically not a good way to play
because the rooks long-range pieces
they're playing up there and so now we
can just attack it and try to trap it
they decide not to not to defend the
rook so you take it so so I could take
the Queen with check but considering I'm
a much better a player you probably do
not want to trade the Queen's at this
point so I get my bishop out Knight
takes the pawn it's a mistake so take
Knight up now give them the Queen check
now if you were playing white what would
you play here we had G 2 2 G 3 right
block the check so it was a bit of hope
chest on my part hoping that they would
move the King to get out of the check
yes and so Castle and this is not gonna
be checkmate unfortunately because after
Knight up rook takes he created a flight
square a flight square is a place where
the King can go and to get out of check
flight square so I'm good
alright yeah just take the Queen
and now we need to start thinking about
checkmate
we actually have well we do not have
checkmate here but if you really want to
think about checkmate what moves would
you be considering here Bishop e6
excellent okay because because you want
to get this game done as fast as
possible I wish we could take here and
get the rook we could take the bishop
but we want to get checkmate we want the
nine billion point so Bishop e6 all
right so now e4 that's what I play I
play take the pawn but we have much
better in this position
oh let's let's see if sunder rooms got
and then we'll go to August you one do
you really know what II won is who
should we put on e one yeah is that what
you're as well I guess was gonna say I
totally missed it
Shaq the King cannot move anywhere so he
has to black with the bishop and then
obviously checkmate good job son the
room in August so but Queen takes III
knows now I cannot go to c4 because the
bishop would take the LightSquared
bishop so I take well what well it
because because it's it's because now he
can escape up here
that's very obnoxious so I take the
other bishop now Bishop the d3 and once
again I miss a tactic
23 you're playing just like me but
that's not good that's that good so
that's something else I was considering
but then I think he just plays King sake
take c2 and laughs at me mm-hmm but we
have we have something even better
taking the rook I mean all these
suggestions are fine and winning like
Queen takes e3 is extra was playing the
game rook takes e2 will eventually lead
to White's demise and just take the rook
we probably don't want to do that
sundaram because uh bishop would take
the Queen right but okay so let's just
let you I'll just show Queen takes
III and now g4 now I finally figure out
the tactic here maybe if we look deeper
we have that same tactic last move as
well I'm sure there's a lot of people
yelling at home okay
Komodo rhudi it does not clean c5
alright so notice this Bishop is in a
pin right okay how many different ways
is it attacked by me right now to the
Queen and the knight who is pretend it's
protected twice right by the king and
the pawn what can you tell me about this
pawned it it's stopped correct
so is there a real defender of d3 no so
what move should we play then the Queen
takes d3 check and you see how the pawn
is powerless to take the Queen so the
King moves check b6 that checkmate do we
have any other checkmates in this
position but b6 is the best obviously
not checkmate not checkmate thank lad I
glad you got a ball out of that ok so so
what's the real knight checkmate here
the knight c6 checkmate and we got
another checkmate here is this for real
checkmate there's so many checkmates
okay so that was a good game for me
yes most of these games are one-sided
because they've only been playing for
six weeks so once again I have the black
pieces in this game and now they start
out Knight f3 so I bring my pawn up g4
much better is just simply g3 but
alright g4 so I want to attack the G
pawn here
sure so it doesn't get under attack
right away and I get still theoretically
castle fianchetto the bishop and then I
get castled okay that'd be a nice castle
formation for you okay so g4 yes so
negative 6 would just be walking right
into his plan you feel like I'll attack
you defy much better now we have a
discovered attack and we're covering you
know
efore through b4 here so we're doing
pretty well alright so Knight attacks f7
and protects the pawn
Bishop e6 you think I would play Bishop
e6 in this position no III attack the
knight I attack the night which pawn can
you take here f7 you wouldn't want to
trade a knife for a point as we'll see
in a couple more games coming up so the
night ends up retreating and now we get
free pawn yay yeah so so yeah he really
likes moving his knight around yeah yeah
you got to move other pieces you can't
just be moving this the same guy around
yes so I have two pieces developed and
I'm up upon and he only has one piece
developed on the edge of the board here
okay
yes so now I need to develop more pieces
right or you know control the center
even more okay okay so Sundaram suggests
Bishop to e7 okay I mean he just played
night back to f3 and then I could play E
and he goes here so so that's an idea
except it doesn't win me material so it
does win tempo but tempo means time its
moves tempo like you get free moves
mm-hmm so Knight up just protect the
pawn he gets castle so now we play e4
you know threatening g5 okay so what do
you think the worst move white can make
in this
addition is nope yeah which piece of
white is in a pin it's currently in a
yes yeah so so you probably don't want
to move pieces that are in pins huh yep
so that's not the best move there
so Knight up what am i attacking or is
there any way you can protect that
there's actually two ways we can protect
it no we're we're attacking the H pawn
right now so what's the two ways we can
protect the h2 pawn Knight of three
which of course is played what's the
other one it seriously is have you been
watching this game yes August f4 okay
all right do not see that I did not see
that they get their own pissant action
but then he plays Knight takes and now
he's doing okay yes well what's the
other only other way we can uh yeah pawn
h3 okay the move plays Knight up pawn
takes Bishop takes check King up and
then it's checkmate Queen takes f2 Kings
can't capture protect the pieces
and then the game is over so now I got I
got the black pieces one more time okay
all right just started out a 4 C 5 and a
4 C when you play beginners you got to
watch out for these sort of rooks rings
even though they're not good she's just
gotta watch out now he starts playing a
little bit normal so I decide I'm gonna
play a little bit normal so once again
they come down with the night even
though it's a different player obviously
and this time I'm not concerned about
playing Knight h6 because I can just
castle manually after King takes mmm
interesting so so he says what happens
if I play Queen f3
I probably play Knight f6 have you ever
played Queen up 3 right here I would
just play let's see what I would play so
I could play Knight up 6
d4 well when I'm black here and so d4 is
illegal and I've gotta watch out for
Queen takes f7 check I might play Knight
e5 well if I played d5 so 95 is the best
way because it defends up 7 and attacks
the Queen alright so we have a question
here
so after Queen up 395 Queen here
I could play h6 I know I then nothing's
Lajoie nothing nothing's destroyed
alright a check
right and and I'm doing just fine
okay and then my King can go to h7 and
be all happy okay when he gets cancelled
all right so that would stop his little
threat but he didn't even go for it okay
so King takes e5 right but I'm gonna
castle manually here okay
I had a high no yeah once the King moves
gasoline is off the table right mm-hmm
after he dropped some pieces here there
it is rook f8 okay so now I'm
threatening the castle just by hand okay
manually all right so take so now if you
would take Queen takes d4 here which he
smartly didn't what move would I pound
on the board here
yeah so Knight takes up three check it's
a fork so he takes it and then Bishop
takes Queen and and yeah thank you yeah
thank you
yeah and so instead instead of taking
any place f4 attacks the night so now my
dream of all that is gone and so now I
pushes the pawn a little more so I take
it ye v e5 I don't want to trade the
pawn for Pauling here I'd rather just
take your stuff so now you'll love this
move so this this is when your head is
just not in the game so so he plays the
move kingi to and I'm like oh man he
just unprotected this pot I better take
it obviously I have a much better move
than Knight takes pawn
just take the Queen right yeah take the
Queen yeah that's what I should have
done instead instead I get an idea how I
can win the Queen here
and so now I finally realized I want
that part okay yummy yummy yummy I took
the pun
it's I going back okay so I got the fork
back on all right no now I figure out
another tactic to win the Queen okay
I just don't want to take it I wanna
write so Bishop takes check so now the
Queen and May so now I could take it who
votes that I take it no let's really
think about this okay so so obviously I
could take the Queen here which I could
have taken a long time ago which is a
nine-point piece but the king is worth
nine billion let's let's checkmate the
King here ninety-four check would not
work because Bishop could take c4 so if
I took here he could play Bishop takes
c4 Queen before did you did you read the
thing Queen b3 would drop the Queen okay
all right Queen before I like it alright
so he only has one legal move here do
you see the checkmate sundaram so we're
back to square one here okay so that
Queen takes d4 but you're very close
horrible
do you know it in the back you can see a
checkmate Youth you know check my
obviously August sees finally it's
better be right too
see through yay checkmate yeah
so exciting alright so now we did a big
rematch and I finally get the white
pieces here yep sorry for you 5 so kind
of playing a regular yeah finally so I
got thing yeah I'm not gonna go for that
Ricky Wong yeah for five games they have
the white pieces now I'm taking the
white pieces okay
the hero of course I'm hero so
so unlike all the other games right
they've actually been getting the pieces
off the back row castled defending e5 so
now what do you think obviously night
here is not a good move because it
really attacks nothing and he's on no
mission here what do you think some
ideas for black would be to improve on
than Knight to g4 if you were playing
black I mean what are some ideas you got
an ER do you have any ideas or do you
like his knight move right yeah he
trapped this bishop so so both of the
specific trap so so so he could try
maybe b6 here all right well let's see
what would Knight Orion so let's say he
passes thunder I'm okay why do you think
Knight to g5 would be good here okay so
there's okay let's say it passes again
and now we take take check King takes we
just traded or only two pieces that were
developed right which equal up to six
for a five point rook and a pawn and
look at how many much more development
he has
right so that was not be a good idea to
trade two minor pieces for a rook in a
point right so sudden to him there would
not be a good a good strategy here okay
so so anyway in the game he just goes
Knight to g4 so we like go away and he's
like I'm not going away I'm gonna put my
other night where it can get captured it
was not not the best so I take that one
and then I get the other one and you
just start taking stuff and now we start
thinking about checkmate here I did not
do I'm Poseidon in this position because
I just I want to keep that keep it all
clear I'm thinking about a queen on the
G file checkmate so Bishop takes up six
in this position okay it's black to move
and he does not pick the right move he
tried to play the move f6
it's a right because it's it's a pinned
piece Bishop e7 unfortunately he plays
Queen there and so take and now what is
the fastest way to checkmate this guy
yeah deploy yeah I don't think I'm gonna
get checkmate it down here I think my
Kings doing pretty well
no no 95 horrible night e5 excellent
it's not checkmate but but it's a
clearance
it's a clearance so who do you think I
was making room for when I move my
knight the Queen so night so he says
Knight to g5 with the unstoppable threat
of pawn pawn but he can move the rook
but this is pretty good yeah that's
pretty good
alright so yeah I mean your way is just
a little bit slower than mine alright so
so we get the Queen check and then
where's the checkmate yes excellent
Queen g7 checkmate good job alright and
now we have one last opponent who gets
two tries at this Mariah Mariah okay
yeah well you're gonna rematch you know
well with white one with like yes it's a
girl
okay so d5 take it yeah yeah obviously
black should play Queen takes d5 or
Knight f6 what's your move that's a
happy five blacks turn okay well what
would you play if you were playing white
in this position
illegal you mean Bishop b5 check or
Bishop to c4 to protect the pawn well
let the record show you clearly said c5
but that's alright alright so so yeah
you want to play Bishop c5 check and she
actually helped me out cuz he's actually
gonna put up on on b5 i was like yep and
she blacks with the bishop not the queen
that was good that was good so a for
know we were playing when you take your
hand off the piece Chuck we in takes
Knight protects the poem just take the
knight right yeah she didn't know where
to put the night so she sure was there
so take take and now she's actually has
a threat here can you believe it this is
like the first time I got threatened all
day queen g2 or alright so I you just
develop my night when you're playing
against lower rated opponents especially
when they don't know much what's going
on you don't really want to trade your
power pieces so you really don't wanna
play Queen up three here you played in
that Knight f3 all right so get castle
but that doesn't mean like I shouldn't
get castled and and be safe
and now Queen takes Knight that's too
easy right it's two reasons well
obviously you want to take with the D
pawn so now my queen can become a menace
here so now I want my Queen to become a
menace where's my Queen going here
Queen the d5 yeah Queen the d5 all right
so now we're threatening the pod
we're threatening the rook we're
threatening the check and obviously
can't wait to attack my queen
Chuck all right you got one move so now
what do we want to do yeah that's ready
suggested Knight e5 so 95 what's the
only legal move black has in this but
well not the only move that doesn't fall
to checkmate here f6 you're gonna see
mate failure yeah yeah yeah I love it
all right so so why do what other piece
there what can we have we got it this
Knight f6 yeah not f6 Knight f6 so now
just take the rook let's probably not
take it yet
all right should we take it
I love it
if checkmate yeah all right good job all
right so obviously she did she couldn't
protect it and now we have don't we have
the last match of the day all right once
again I had the white pieces and so just
play good eat 45 fish up up pawn attacks
the bishop I think in a lot of these
beginner games there there there are
making bad moves but they're assuming
that you know hey I'm attacking your
bishop you won't see it I think that's
why a lot of these uh these moves you
see are below average politics ha ha ha
fun takes yes sir
we're not Bishop takes Bishop takes is
not good because then you play Knight of
6 and then I have to waste time moving
my bishop back well Queen takes bishop
would not be good because I could just
take it back all right so pawn takes c6
so we can just take it and take it back
a knight attacks the pawn h5 so we just
take the pawn
in this position there was a good move
for black I don't believe it
all right where's the good move well
let's hear what Sundaram has to say
before before I do like efore here efore
and yeah II four five no no no let's
protect the f7 point somehow maybe with
Bishop e6
I mean it's unfortunate that we have to
play like that but that's all that's all
the only chance we have all right but
but the game preceded h5 took the pawn
bishop up Bishop check King up all right
what's what's your suggestion Sundaram
all right so you're you're just playing
like like the kid now because guess what
I just take the knight all right all
right so so the move obviously is d3
that way I can get castled and I can get
check here so Knight to d7 now sundaram
you might be on to something
cuz black just voluntarily removed the
defender the defender of c6 but don't
worry I didn't play it anyway either
I got cancelled so so now you see
Sundaram your Knight takes c6 check
actually works in this position
oh well first I play my check cuz I was
real I had my heart set on that check
yeah now Knight to c6 is recommended but
but first I get castle okay
and they defended yep
so Queen to e2 Knight g6 check
they'll take check King back I mean it
yeah there we could check with the Queen
but but now he's getting away
okay so so sometimes as they say the as
it's on t-shirts and everything the the
threat is better than the execution okay
so instead of playing this will threaten
to play it with Queen e2 okay then we'll
have double check okay and you see how
much better this is because after Knight
g6 if he takes look at this mate
okay but obviously I don't see it okay
so so so Knight g6 check is the best
move here but instead I said I'm going
for that Queen Knight takes c6 check
luckily the player plays the worst move
here King D 7 so I have much better than
then
yeah
so there's something for everyone we
just saw the worst move in chess history
all right Shaq and may alright so so
those are some beginner games hopefully
you won't fall for the follies okay all
right thank you very much